what up theo what up brandon shout out
culture corner
from las vegas i joined the circus early
i'm a street performer on the strip i do
live art
what do you think about street
performers king understing it people
that pretty much work without a captive
audience for tips or
do dance music really anything let me
know what you think
gang gang huff huh oh damn
damn machine gun kelly
that's that street version that's that
alley cat version machine gun kelly son
he's got that tig notaro vibe as well
he's funnier
[Laughter]
well so look we got to support this
man's art if you out there you see that
man buy that
buy it street art i think is hard i
think it's easier if it's not raining i
think if you see somebody doing it in
the rain you got to buy it i agree
um i think it's dope dude and now in
venice there's only so many houses it's
hard to
figure out what's good what's [ __ ]
someone who's
kind of a journeyman because if you
remember there's the one-man band down
there
he he literally played nine instruments
at a time there was the dude who walked
on glass this dude who swallowed swords
yeah yeah then they then they got those
painters there was the electric guy i
think he passed away yeah he was on
rollerblades played the electric guitar
yeah he got eight he got aids i think oh
he did
i don't know if he did
i was in vegas on colder skates dude
with no pants on dude
there'd be a 50 chance i would you know
you didn't catch something give me an hi
you know and that guy that guy left no
contact info but his name is daz gerina
well we know where he's at though you
know so he's on the strip out there so i
think street performers
i like it i don't like it though when it
gets to the point where they're wasting
my time the dancers you know
i don't like when they put the pressure
on you like come on come on close
everybody
come on close don't be all the way out
there and then they give you the hat to
put in money it's like yeah damn dude or
they take a little six-year-old girl out
there and she's in a coma or something
and they just set her by a mic and
they'll put on like a like a
previously recorded thing and then just
have him be like that and you're like
what the
[ __ ] dude like that kind of shits too
much when they're bad they're bad
right but it's not like don't trick me
out of my money like you still got to be
you know i respect the hustle and then
the talent so yeah i respect the hustle
but you can't don't just try to you know
put somebody out there that's dead or
something and be like oh you know
give us your money yeah listen to this
uh tina turner while you look at
freaking ronnie he's dead you know he's
like
i'm not giving a dollar to that but i
hate it when the dancer guys
make you it takes so long that's what
i'm saying like the build-up it's a real
clock tease for about an
hour yeah yeah come on everybody getting
closer then they do a little thing like
oh not yet
and then everybody closer closer you
over there i know you're enjoying
yourself come up you're like
damn dude yeah i'm just trying is that
your robot yeah
what's up doug what's up that was okay i
used to be on third street
damn i like it thanks man it's good that
was different
all right and i got that hoodie on too
this week man
ooh don't touch you but keep touching
yeah limited i got that limited range of
potion baby